and uh one check is enough to force the  black king in front but here surely it's  a matter of technique dude is unhappy  here the black king could just move in  and  it's gonna guide its pawn forward this  is a simple win now wow let's go back to  the players we're about to see a result  black's b pawn  is going to win the day  the bar jumps up to  5.6 for lavon aronian this is game two  the first one ended with a draw he has  the black pieces in this one and levon  aronian about to go one point up in the  match  look at dude that is frustrated five  seconds on the clock  but i guess there's no save  there is absolutely no save and uh he's  let the clock run down yeah  uh aronian takes the first point wow  levon aronian he takes the lead in the  semi-final match against young christoph  duda a great game no smile on his face  looks very concentrated